people don't know this about george
lopez's career
20 years after you started at the comedy
store
sandra bullock discovered quote unquote
you yes an executive produced the george
lopez show that was on abc for six
seasons yes and she is the one who went
out and said let me you know in a way
it's kind of weird she was like i'm
going to go find a latino performer
who i think is happening right it was
that the story was that it she had an
idea that had more teenagers as the
central figures and then when she saw my
act she said i think i'd like to try to
see what you have
what you have in there what'd she do she
came down to a comedy yeah she came to
the improv in brea which is like an hour
and a half outside of los angeles so she
was really active she was miss
congeniality at that time the night that
you uh met her and she came down to see
you were you aware she was in the
audience
yes i was you are and did you know what
she was looking for she was just you
thought she was there for a night of
entertainment to come see uh george
lopez yeah and you know she was she
lives in austin so like a year before
she went to see chappelle one weekend
and i was there the next weekend right
and um she was gonna come in but at that
time i was drinking a lot and very
sloppy on stage uh not as not as defined
and i i literally prayed to god please
don't let her come in here and see me
like this somebody you were high for
that uh i was a little drunk you know
not not not as legit as you would like
to be because when you're doing clubs
it's just such a [ __ ] grind that
you're just trying to get through the
time at some point
because you do the same thing every
night she saw me at the right time of my
life like i cleaned up a little bit and
did that yeah and then what does she do
she calls you up and says listen i have
an idea for you to do a sitcom we met
and and then uh
started to go over the people in my life
and my grandmother was one and the wife
and the kids and stuff so uh yeah wow
and and sandra bullock do you begin to
like think like oh my god this is my
savior i mean she really really believed
that you know what she really didn't
take no for an answer and it's right and
why do you think you were trying to get
out of it no but the network didn't want
you but yeah yeah when you first go into
your first sitcom and you've been doing
stand-up your whole life and yeah yeah i
assume you hadn't had much acting
training and stuff are you nervous about
doing a sick because it's very different
than uh well the funny thing is we you
know we finished the script right before
2002 and we started to to rehearse
actors but real actors yeah so the guy
that plays my best friend valenti he
came in right before christmas break and
he was an actor so i'm reading with him
and i'm [ __ ] horrible
right i'm like
from a [ __ ]
you know
what what's going on hey
awful awful [ __ ] horrible and the two
guys look at me like uh uh they just
look at me and say oh [ __ ] like they see
that that i can't act who are the two
guys i mean the guys from the network
bruce helpful my guys helfer did uh drew
carey worked on roseanne and then robert
borden worked with him and then i ended
up getting a coach over the christmas
break and i had her the whole run of the
show right because you have to all of a
sudden learn a whole new skill set here
you are going on network television and
people expect oh he was a stand-up comic
he should have no problem acting [ __ ]
man you were that bad huh pretty bad and
what did they do english is my official
[ __ ] language and i was still [ __ ]
horrible at it
hi everybody how are you guys doing look
at the petroleum
you